حرب اوكرانيا القت بحمل ثقيل على الدول
الاوروبيه
فالمخسونه العسكريه استنفذت بسبب الحرب
هشاشه سلاسل التوريده العسكريه دفعت وكاله
الدفاع الاوروبيه للاعلان عن الحاجه
الماسه لتغطيه ضعف مخزوناتها خاصه وان
الاعتماد على حليفه واشنطن وحدها لن
يحميها من اي تهديد
الولايات المتحده
اسيا والمحيط الهاتف ولن تكون قادره على
توفير بعض العناصر الدفاعيه الاساسيه لذلك
نجري محادثات مع شركات اسلحه اوروبيه بشان
زياده الانتاج وكذلك مع دول الاتحاد لشراء
المعدات والذخيره بشكل مشترك
تسريحات وكاله الدفاع الاوروبيه اعاده
التفكير حول مبدا العمل بالقوه الاوروبيه
المشتركه التي تم احيائها في مارس الماضي
بقاء من يتالف من 5000 جندي للاستجابه
السريعه وهي ضمن محاولات الاتحاد
الاوروبيه للاستقلاليه الدفاعيه وفك
الارتباط مع امريكا
الا انه لم ياتي ثماره بسبب النهج الدفاعي
الاوربيه
ما ادى لانتاج خليط من الاسلحه والمعدات
غير المتوافقه وخليل وظيفي في الدفاع رغم
المحاولات المتاخره من الوكاله الدفاع
الاوروبيه لمعالجه الخلل بدء من توحيد
الجهود والتمويل
اذا بدون مساعده الولايات المتحده سيكافح
الاتحاد الاوروبي للدفاع عن نفسه حيث
يفتقر للمعلومات الاستخباراتيه والطائرات
الاستطلاع والدفاع الصاروخيه متوسطه وكذلك
السفن البرمائيه والغواصات
بجانب الاعداد العسكريه الروسيه الضخم
والتلويح باستخدام الترسانه النوويه
رغم طموح الاتحاد الاوروبي للاستقلاليه عن
امريكا الا ان دول اخرى تعرضوا تلك الفكره
في مطلع ديسمبر الجاري اعترافه الحكومه
الفنديه بان اوروبا ستعاني بدون الولايات
المتحده والاخيره تؤكد اهميه ان يبقى
القوه الاساسيه في مواجهه التهديدات روان
حمزه العربي